hi everyone Brian green here and I hope
you are doing well or at least as well
as you can be doing in these
extraordinary times and with so many
people at home we thought it might be
fun and interesting to start a new
series called your daily equation in
which each day what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna pick one pivotal equation and
describe where it comes from why it's
true and what it tells us about the deep
workings of reality and I got to tell
you my view is that in these in these
difficult times math and equations are a
really powerful really wonderful tool
for allowing us even for just a brief
moment to rise above the details of
what's happening in our lives around the
world allowing us to transcend the
problems of the moment and have a little
bit of of mental breathing space a
little bit of mind reset which is so
vital so important and look many people
will achieve this or or or try to
achieve this in different ways through
through literature through film through
art through music we together are going
to do this through the language of
mathematics seeing the world through the
power of equations and look even if even
if math is not your thing give it a shot
because the change in perspective that
you can reach by seeing the world
through the lens of mathematics can be
deeply satisfying so I'm going to begin
tomorrow Thursday 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time
and I'm going to start in the first
episode with the most famous of all
equations you know which equation that
is Einsteins e equals MC squared and
from there each day we will go on
excursions these will be brief
breezy informal excursions that will
allow us to engage with the world in a
slightly different way so again we're
gonna start tomorrow first episode
Thursday
3 p.m. Eastern Time join us I am looking
forward to it see you then